zdf heute live herzlich willkommen wir
gehen aus anlass der flutkatastrophe
direkt nach koblenz zu einer
pressekonferenz dort ins
polizeipräsidium
mit dabei sind der polizeipräsident und
unter anderem der leitende
oberstaatsanwalt und wir hören direkt
rein
ja dann wollen wir auch beginnen sie
nicht länger auf die folter spannen
herzlich willkommen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren der medien sie recht
herzlich hier zur pressekonferenz
anlässlich der flutkatastrophe in
hartheim müsste ihnen kurz noch sagen
dass wir gleich beginnen werden mit
einem sehr beeindruckenden video unserer
polizei hubschrauberstaffel die das
ganze ausmaß der katastrophe ihnen dann
dort nochmal zeigt wenn sie uns später
eine e mail schicken die adresse blenden
wir dann noch ein können wir ihnen
dieses video auch gerne zur verfügung
stellen grüße an dieser stelle zunächst
mal unseren gast ganz außen haben den
leiter der staatsanwaltschaft koblenz
leitenden oberstaatsanwalt arbeit kurse
herzlich willkommen in ihrem haus mal
wieder von vorne beginnen begrüße ich
weiterhin den hausherren in karenz maren
neben ihm ist der gesamteinsatzleiter
der polizei für diesen einsatz polizei
vizepräsident jürgen süß ich würde jetzt
dann das wort an maron gleich übergeben
oder sie übernähmen dann gleich wenn das
video abgespielt ist
etwa vier minuten
ja liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
wir sehen hier die bilder die die
polizei aus koblenz zur verfügung stellt
sind bilder aus der luft wie wir sie das
muss man sagen so noch nie gesehen haben
dieses wie gesagt dass polizei material
was zur verfügung gestellt wird auch wir
journalisten journalistinnen haben in
den letzten tagen
diese bilder gezeigt und sie sehen aber
sie zeigen das ganze ausmaß der
katastrophe
117 tote gibt es in diesem bereich in
rheinland pfalz vor allem in den
bereichen im kreis ahrweiler und man
sieht welche wucht das wasser hatte
welches ausmaß der zerstörung
welche schäden dort angerichtet wurden
wie viel gebiete überflutet wurden
während diese bilder zu sehen sind
hoffen immer noch angehörige dass ihre
verwandten gerettet werden können von
einsatzkräften die in diesen gebieten
die wir hier gerade sehen
vor ort sind feuerwehren aus ganz
deutschland das technische hilfswerk die
bundeswehr sucht in diesen minuten noch
nach verschütteten
nach menschen die seit tagen
eingeschlossen sind in ihren häusern die
weggespült wurden vom wasser und die man
jetzt mit sehr wenig hoffnung darauf
dass sie überlebt haben
suchen und finden will
wir sehen diese bilder nicht nur aus
rheinland pfalz wie in diesem fall
sondern auch aus nordrhein-westfalen
auch hier hat das große zerstörungen
gegeben
der innenminister war heute morgen vor
ort und hat sich ein bild von der lage
gemacht und auch horst seehofer hat sich
bestürzt gezeigt über das was er dort
gesehen hat und schnelle hilfe
angekündigt wir dürfen diese menschen
nicht alleine lassen hat er gesagt und
schon dann mittwoch wird sich das
kabinett damit befassen welche hilfen
man zur verfügung stellen kann
die polizei hat diese pressekonferenz
anberaumt um vor allem darüber zu
informieren welche anlaufstellen die
menschen jetzt vor ort haben wo sie sich
hinwenden können wenn sie menschen
vermissen wie viele das im moment sind
das weiß man nicht genau
ende letzter woche ging man noch von
1.300 vermissten aus wie viele es jetzt
sind kann man nicht genau sagen weil die
meldesysteme noch nicht abgeglichen
werden konnten weil an vielen orten auch
noch das handynetz nicht wieder aktiv
ist und weil an vielen orten der strom
auch fehlt also hier weiß man einfach
noch nicht genau mit wie vielen
vermissten im moment tatsächlich zu
rechnen ist
aber die polizei wird auch informationen
darüber geben wie die toten
identifiziert werden welche arbeit im
moment vor ort gemacht wird und wie den
menschen vor ort geholfen werden kann
wir werden gleich im verlauf der sendung
auch noch zu meinem kollegen bobby
cherry anschalten der vor ort ist im
kreis ahrweiler in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler
er ist schon seit einigen tagen in
diesem gebiet unterwegs und kann
berichten wie die leute dort versuchen
ihr leben wieder aufzubauen und jetzt
wieder zurück nach koblenz
sehr geehrte damen und herren abfahrt
noch erkennt zum vorstellen weitere
unsere kriminaldirektion der stephan
hains der auch wesentliche dieser
einsatzbewältigung beteiligten auch
gleich aus seiner sicht erfahrungen
schildert ja sehr verehrte damen und
herren hier sitzen sicherlich sehr
erfahren polizei kriminalbeamter die
über große berufserfahrung verfügen auch
gerade mit der führung polizei
niederlagen und der bewältigung an der
vielzahl von der lag angefangen vom
kaiser lagen über größere
schadensereignisse aber auch sehr
polizei erfahren und polizei haben die
seit mittwochnacht vor ort eingesetzt
sind bestätigen meine bewerten dass
diese einsatzlage eine ganz besondere
herausforderung für alle einsatz und
hilfskräfte darstellung die polizei in
diesem einsatz in diese
einsatzbewältigung komtax ihren
originären aufgaben der gefahrenabwehr
strafverfolgung
ach und unterstützt dort wo es geht und
wo es möglich ist auf vielfältige weise
die hilfsorganisationen wie feuerwehr
wie thw wie viele andere wir wollen und
wir sind tag und nacht mit der vielzahl
von einsatzkräften aus einer pfalz von
allen behörden in einer pfalz aber auch
aus dem gesamten bundesgebiet präsent
für die bürger zur hilfeleistung als
ansprechpartner und zum schutz ihres
eigentums
ich konnte mir von den verheerenden
ausschreitungen auswirkungen vor ort in
bad neuenahr-ahrweiler im schuld in suhl
ein eigenes bild machen und glauben sie
mir dass es alles viel viel schlimmer
als wie man das auf bildern oder von
videos wahrnehmen kann auch wie sie es
jetzt ihr eingangs gesehen haben wenn
sie in einer notunterkunft ein ehepaar
treffen beide über 80 jahre alt die
alles verloren haben und jetzt auf noten
liegen die nacht verbringen müssen
sie warten auf ihren sohn der sie
abholen will von oberstdorf kommen wenn
sie mit einem menschen sprechen der
nicht nur sein haus den nicht nur sein
haus zerstört wurde sondern auch die
firma in der er über 40 jahre arbeitet
die in gänze weggespült worden ist wenn
sie unmittelbar miterleben wie eine
tochter ihrem krad nach über 14 stunden
aus abend auf einem dach geretteten
vater in die arme
und wenn sie mit kollegen sprechen die
eine vielzahl von leichenbergen müssen
dann vergessen sie das nicht so leicht
und bekommen einen unmittelbaren
eindruck von großem leid vor ort und auf
der großen belastung für alle die lust
mehr als polizeipräsident in koblenz ist
ganz wichtig
dass die polizei vor ort präsent ist und
für den bürger da ist deshalb auch hier
dass wir wirklich sehr wichtig mein
appell an die bürger wo immer es möglich
ist können sie auf die polizei zu gehen
sich mit fragen an die polizei wenden
informieren sie sich bei der polizei
bediensteten entweder vor ort oder über
twitter oder facebook
es gibt leider auch in dieser
einsatzlage gerüchte und mutmaßungen
gerade auch in den sozialen medien die
immer wieder für verunsicherung sorgen
als ein beispiel es hat sich dann in
eine sehr früh das geräusch festgesetzt
werden dann geboren und es würde jetzt
noch mal weitergehen da war natürlich
nichts sagen erst dann in schuld hat der
bürgermeister die bundeskanzlerin
gefragt und da stimmen würde das die
bundeswehr abgezogen werden würde usw
es gibt vielfältige beispiele deswegen
mein appell wir als polizei werden alles
versuchen um den bürgern vor ort zu
helfen wir sind ansprechbar und wir
werden auch die nächste zeit mit hoher
präsenz vor ort anwesend sein würde
jetzt auch gern die gelegenheit nutzen
dem einsatzleiter und
ohnehin schon mal vorab zu danken für
die wirklich große arbeit die die
momentan leisten für unsere würden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
möchte ihnen die lage aus sicht der
polizei vorstellen im landkreis
ahrweiler leben und 130.000 bürgerinnen
und bürger auf eine strecke von etwa 50
kilometer entlang des flusses
insgesamten von dieser katastrophe über
30 ortschaften betroffen davon einige
besonders mehrere campingplatz plätze
entlang der aa wurden ebenfalls zerstört
sind weitere immense schäden entstanden
deren ausmaß abschließend noch zu
erheben ist in dem gebiet sind durch die
überflutung mehrere häuser zerstört und
bewohner oder vollständig weggerissen
viele straßen und brücken wurden
zerstört und sind nicht mehr nutzbar
die versorgungsanlagen für frisch und
abwasser strom und telekommunikations in
den großen teilen zerstört es wird lange
zeit brauchen diese infrastruktur wieder
herzustellen
mir ist wichtig auch noch einen moment
über gefahren zu sprechen
nach wie vor bestehen sowohl für die
bürgerin
bürger als auch für die eingesetzten
kräfte
ich möchte beispielsweise hinweisen
hinweisen auf stromleitungen die
bestätigt auch mit bodenkontakt zu
verzeichnen sind
wir müssen weiterhin sehr vorsichtig
sein
einen überblick der polizei ausgedrückt
in zahlen insgesamt gibt es zum
derzeitigen zeitpunkt 117 tote 754
personen wurden mit stand jetzt durch
die überflutungen verletzt
die telefonische aus und stelle der
polizei nahm mehrere tausend hinweise
seit mittwochabend entgegen und 4000
dieser hinweise konnten bereits
bearbeitet werden im moment sind rund
900 weitere hinweise in der bearbeitung
während der letzten tage gingen genau 47
hinweise ein zu möglichen straftaten von
denen 14 als tatsächliche straftaten
klassifiziert werden konnten das sind
straftaten überwiegend am unteren
bereich der eigentumskriminalität
zur kräfte disposition und zur kräfte
lage der polizei alle polizeipräsidien
des landes rheinland-pfalz alle
bundesländer die benachbarten nationen
und alle polizeibeamten polizeibeamten
des pk plans arbeiten gemeinsam daran
mit dieser katastrophe umzugehen
als beispiel möchte ich ihnen sagen dass
wir alleine heute über tag mehr als 1200
polizeibeamte im katastrophengebiet und
in den anderen aufgaben einsetzen
der polizeipräsident hat es bereits
ausgeführt wir sind seit mittwochnacht
mit ganz starken polizeikräften im
einsatz sowohl tagsüber als auch nachts
wir haben ausgegeben bereits am mittwoch
dass in jeder ortschaft zu jeder zeit
polizei präsent bei den leitlinien bei
den aktuellen leitlinien ist es mir
wichtig bei aller tragik nach vorn zu
schauen
die polizei kommt zu den menschen
wir möchten durch sehr starke präsenz in
den betroffenen regionen für die
menschen ansprechpartner sein und auch
sehr unkonventionelle hilfe leisten
die inhaltlichen schwerpunkte im und um
das katastrophengebiet ist es ganz
wichtig die verkehrswege frei zu halten
um den ungestörten einsatz der
rettungsdienste und der polizei zu
gewährleisten und darüber hinaus
natürlich
auch transporte die jetzt anlaufen um
die infrastruktur wieder herzustellen
die absuche die erneute absolutes
geländes führender derzeit gemeinsam mit
der technischen einsatzleitung und damit
mit kräften der feuerwehr und der
rettungsdienste und auch der bundeswehr
mit hochdruck durch
es werden dass es abzusehen weitere
absuchen erfolgen müssen
getötete menschen werden von vom
auffinden über die verbringung zu einer
sammelstelle bis hin zum überbringen der
endgültigen todesnachricht mit
größtmöglicher pietät behandelt die
bürgerinnen bürger bitten wir an dieser
stelle sich unter der bekannten und
veröffentlichen rufnummer an die
personenauskunftsstelle zu melden wenn
es hinweise gibt zu vermissten oder
insbesondere jede aufgefundenen personen
das würde uns sehr helfen dabei die
derzeit in bearbeitung befindlichen
hinweise abschließen zu können
in den betroffenen gemeinden hat die
polizei in vorbereitung über das
bestehende angebot hinaus anlaufstellen
oder sogenannte informationsstellen
einzurichten
an diesen stellen soll ein direkter
kontakt
an diesen anlauf oder informationen
stellen soll es möglich sein dass die
bevölkerung mit der blaulicht familie
unmittelbar in kontakt tritt
die vorstellung ist in jeder ortschaft
quasi eine die kleine dienststellen der
blaulicht von mineralien zu richten
das werden wir zunächst tagsüber
gewährleisten da muss aber keine sorge
bestehen die polizei wird auch nachts zu
jeder zeit in jeder ortschaft präsenz in
der öffentlichkeitsarbeit liegt unser
besonderes augenmerk auf den sozialen
medien um mit größtmöglicher reichweite
möglichst umfassend zu informieren und
falschen informationen frühzeitig
entgegen zu treten das scheint uns
offensichtlich ganz gut zu gelingen wir
haben alleine durchschnittlich auf
twitter technischen reichweite von über
700.000 zugriffen
ich möchte eine der vielen aufgaben noch
herausgreifen das ist der einsatz
unserer hubschrauber die in diese
einsatzlagen mit zerstörter
infrastruktur von ganz besonderen wert
sind wir verwenden die hubschrauber zu
vielfältigen aufgaben beginnend
aufklärungsmaßnahmen luft verfrachtung
von polizei und rettungskräften bis hin
zur gewährleistung der grundversorgung
der bevölkerung in der letzten nacht
beispielsweise die versorgung mit gas
und mit treibstoff
ich möchte sie nicht versorgen auch die
ganzen servicebereiche in der polizei an
zu sprechen die es möglich machen dass
die polizei vor ort diese wichtige
aufgabe erfüllen kann
ich möchte mich zum ende kommend mit
einem ab
an die bürger richten begeben sie sich
nicht in gefahr und halten sie bitte die
rettungswege frei vertrauen sie auf die
arbeit der rettungsdienste und der
polizei
wir sind für sie da zu jeder tages und
nachtzeit jeder polizeibeamte steht
ihnen für fragen zur verfügung egal
welcher art sprechen sie uns bitte an
wir werden ihnen mit allen unseren
möglichkeiten helfen
abschließend möchte ich schon
verständnis bitten wenn in dieser doch
sehr schwierigen lage der polizei ein
fehler unterläuft bei allen
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamten und
den kräften der blaulicht familie möchte
ich mich bereits jetzt bedanken und
bitten sich weiter mit aller kraft für
die menschen einzusetzen
vielen dank tja so weit der
polizeipräsident von koblenz karl-heinz
maronn der noch einmal zusammengefasst
hat wie schrecklich die lage ist 117
tote 750 verletzte und 900 hinweise sagt
er sind derzeit in bearbeitung das heißt
es gibt 900 hinweise darauf dass
menschen vermisst werden
wie viel das de facto sind das muss man
eben im moment prüfen 900 hinweise heißt
nicht 900 vermisste sondern man muss
abgleichen ob vielleicht eine einige
personen mehrfach vermisst gemeldet
wurden und man darf nur hoffen dass die
zahl der tatsächlichen toten am ende
weit weit weit unter dieser eben
genannten zahl liegt wir wollen dorthin
blicken wo es einen ort besonders schwer
getroffen hat nämlich nach bad neuenahr
ahrweiler dort ist mein kollege bobby
cherry an bobby kannst du uns
beschreiben wie die situation dort im
moment ist
wer die menschen versuchen hier stück
für stück weg zu schaffen was die was
das hochwasser hier halt hinterlassen
hat das sind bilder die haben wir schon
in ganz vielen ortschaften gesehen das
heißt hier in den straßen rund um die a
sehen wir menschen seit heute früh in
die häuser reingehen aus den häusern
raus kommen schubkarren voller schlamm
also wirklich eine schubkarre nach der
nächsten rausbringen die versuchen hier
irgendwie auf einen haufen zu schütten
es geht wieder rein und die nächste
schubkarre mit schlamm kommt raus dazu
ganz viele möbel die alle in den
erdgeschosswohnungen oder halt im
erdgeschoss der häuser in
mitleidenschaft gezogen worden sind
dementsprechend auch nicht mehr zu
gebrauchen sind das sind riesige
sammlungen riesige haufen die sich hier
ergeben dass das ist das eine was die
menschen machen sie versuchen hier so
stück für stück mit dieser katastrophe
klarzukommen und dagegen an zu arbeiten
wenn man aber bedenkt dass das jetzt tag
5 ist nach dem hochwasser und im grunde
aber auch die bilder immer noch die
gleichen sind wie an tag eins dann weiß
man es dauert alles unglaublich lange
und es wird auch noch sehr sehr lange
dauern
natürlich kommt dann auch noch hinzu
dass die menschen erschöpft sind auf der
einen seite sind sie einfach körperlich
erschöpft mental aber auch das ist ein
schock der unglaublich tief sitzt und
natürlich die gedanken um die toten um
verletzte und vermisste
all das spielt hier auch eine ganz große
rolle
bevor ich mit der zweiten frage zu dir
kommen an der stelle eine korrektur das
war eben vizepräsident jürgen süß den
ich da falsch tituliert habe sorry falls
das muss noch korrigiert werden und an
dieser stelle auch der freundliche und
herzliche hinweis an sie liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
schreiben sie uns ihre fragen und
vielleicht auch wenn sie vor ort etwas
berichten können
in die kommentarspalten bei social media
oder per e mail an die eingeblendete e
mail adresse bobby du hast angesprochen
dass es sehr lange dauert und dass man
so wenig fortschritt sieht liegt das
daran gibt es da kritik in die richtung
dass es zu wenig koordiniert ist dass es
zu wenig staatliche hilfe ist oder woran
liegt das wir hören und sehen es gibt
sehr viele freiwillige helfer vor ort
aber vielleicht kannst du dazu was sagen
wie das koordiniert wird und ob es
vielleicht schneller gehen müsste das
ist so eine frage ob jetzt mehr
staatliche hilfe nötig wäre oder nicht
die hört man also diesen vorwurf habe
ich jetzt noch nicht so häufig gehört
ich war ende der vergangenen woche hier
in der region unterwegs jetzt eben
wieder und das ist so etwas was die
leute zurzeit nicht umtreibt also
wahrscheinlich schon vielleicht
untereinander aber für uns haben sie es
jetzt nicht groß formuliert weil es
andere sachen sind die die leute jetzt
gerade beschäftigen und zwar diese ganz
einfachen dinge
wir stehen hier in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler im stadtteil
ahrweiler der zurzeit immer noch kein
fließend wasser hat kein strom kein gas
und das sind so die fragen die die leute
jetzt beschäftigen was ist mit dem haus
kann ich hier überhaupt wohnen bleiben
zahlt meine versicherung den schaden
ich denke diese fragen wer hat trägt
hier eigentlich welche verantwortung
inwieweit hätte gewarnt werden müssen
wer müsste jetzt eigentlich mehr
koordinieren die sind sicher irgendwo
auch da aber gerade stehen halt ganz
einfache dinge im vordergrund und da
sind die leute hier froh dass ist
hilfsangebote gibt klar die freiwilligen
helferinnen und helfer sind das eine
aber es gibt ja auch offizielle stellen
also wir haben hier die bundeswehr schon
gesehen die damit beschäftigt war wasser
aus der aa in ein extra dafür
angeschafftes becken also ein pool er
einen normalen hausgebrauch pool zu
pumpen nur damit die leute sich irgendwo
zumindest wasser braucht wasser holen
können um den schlamm wegzuschwimmen der
jetzt trocknet und sonst nicht anders
weg ging also das sind die fragen die
die leute hier beschäftigen auch dass
das thw gerade damit beschäftigt ist
eine telekommunikations leitung aus dem
stadtteil bad neuenahr nach ahrweiler
durch die a zulegen weil hier einfach
nichts mehr funktioniert das sind die
fragen die die leute beschäftigen
erstmal das wichtigste zu klären wieder
angebunden zu werden und ich denke diese
großen fragen nach verantwortung sicher
die stellen sich im nachgang und so ein
stück weit koordination ist ja
offensichtlich da ansonsten wären auch
solche kräfte wie bundeswehr und thw
nicht vor ort bobby hier schreibt über
facebook paola goncalves viel erfolg und
viel kraft
wünsche ich euch mein beileid an die
familien die ihre liebsten verloren
haben also wir sehen hier in der
community sehr viel mit gefühl und auch
sehr viele angebote zu helfen oder oder
zumindest das emotional mitzutragen wenn
sie helfen wollen dann möchten wir an
der stelle noch einmal auf den spenden
hinweis auch das zdf verweisen über die
homepage auf zdf de können sie auch
spenden hier sehen wir das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe die
iban der e65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser deutschland wie
gesagt sie finden die links auch bei uns
in den kommentaren und auf unserer
homepage bobby noch einmal zu dir kannst
du noch einmal du hast gerade sehr
anschaulich beschrieben was die leute
vor ort brauchen kannst du noch einmal
das ist ja unvorstellbar für alle die
die ihre häuser haben und diese bilder
in den nachrichten sehen kannst du noch
einmal beschreiben wie gehen die leute
zum beispiel damit um dass ihre häuser
keine türen mehr haben die man
abschließen kann
gleichzeitig kann man aber auch nicht
mehr in den häusern wohnen sondern muss
bei freunden unterkommen oder in
notunterkünften
wir regeln die leute das haben die angst
dass ihr hab und gut gestohlen wird
versuchen die in diesen häusern zu
bleiben so gut es irgendwie geht weil
sie einfach da sein wollen und weil das
das letzte stückchen sicherheit ist was
ihnen geblieben ist
da gibt es sowohl das eine als auch das
andere es gibt die einen die tatsächlich
nicht hier sind also deren häuser in
mitleidenschaft gezogen worden sind und
die außerhalb untergekommen sind bei
freunden vielleicht bei der familie
vielleicht weil sie das glück haben
irgendwo noch ein ferienhaus oder
ähnliches zu haben was dann natürlich
sehr komfortabel ist aber eben auch die
menschen in den notunterkünften also
einige sind auch in notunterkünften in
wie sie es nannten auffang camps
untergebracht und die kommen dann
morgens hierhin in ihre häuser versuchen
dann
da so weit klar schiff zu machen wie sie
es eben schaffen an einem tag gehen
zurück in ihre behelfs unterkunft und
kommen dann wieder in den arealen um die
es da geht da muss man leider sagen ist
auch aus also aus meiner sicht nicht
mehr viel zu holen
die menschen kümmern sich darum den
schlamm raus zu kippen und die kaputten
möbel rauszubringen da ist auch nichts
mehr zu holen
dann gibt es aber auch menschen die hier
geblieben sind weil sie als das
hochwasser kam die möglichkeit hatten
vielleicht in den ersten stock zu
flüchten oder in den zweiten die dann
sagen hier in meinem haus ist das
erdgeschoss zwar hin aber wir harren
weiter aus wir bleiben im ersten
obergeschoss wohnen
ich habe von einer familie gehört dass
es ein mehrgenerationenhaus also da
wohnen die eltern beziehungsweise
schwiegereltern mit im haus die haben
vorher im erdgeschoss gewohnt das geht
jetzt nicht mehr jetzt wurden alle
zusammen in der ersten etage teil teilen
sich darauf auf kinderbetten oder
feldbetten oder ähnliches auch diese
möglichkeit gibt es ohne wasser ohne
strom waren die leute dann hier aus weil
sie ihr zu hause auch nicht verlassen
wollen und im grunde kann man ja auch
verstehen dass die menschen da bleiben
wollen wir haben damals vergangen ende
der vergangenen woche
es ist ja noch nicht lange her in schuld
waren wir da stationiert und da ging es
tatsächlich darum in der nacht von
donnerstag auf freitag dass es
ablagerungen gegeben hat nachdem das
hochwasser dadurch ist viel mitgerissen
hat teile des ortes abgesperrt waren
weil sie instabil und einsturzgefährdet
waren
da gab es dann tatsächlich in der nacht
auch noch plünderungen insofern kann man
nachvollziehen dass einige menschen hier
auch sagen nein egal wie desolat die
lage ist egal wie schlimm es um mein
zuhause steht wenn irgendein teil noch
bewohnbar ist bleibe ich hier drin und
passe halt weiter auf wo wir eine letzte
frage noch weil wir auch gerade einen
traktor gesehen haben der hinter dir
durchs bild gefahren ist auf der anderen
flussseite olaf köhler fragt über
facebook oder sagt über facebook in
einigen orten waren noch kein
hilfsdienst nur die bauern räumen auf
wir haben gelernt auch in solchen
katastrophen gibt es viel wahrheit und
auch viele gerüchte ist das ein gerücht
oder ist das was was du auch aus seinen
recherchen vor ort berichten kannst dass
es gebiete gibt in die
überhaupt noch niemand so richtig
vorgedrungen ist also ich kann jetzt
nicht für alle gebiete sprechen ich habe
ja auch nur einige gesehen und bei der
menge an gebieten die hier betroffenen
es wäre es ja auch vermessen zu sagen
ich hätte den überblick über alle in den
gebieten in denen wir waren in schuld in
insul jetzt hier in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler sind jedesmal kräfte
vor ort gewesen sein ist jetzt die
sanitäter die feuerwehr das thw in
schuld war auch die bundeswehr mit einem
speziellen räumpanzer dann am freitag
schon vor ort bei dem man dann sah der
ist zu klein es muss noch neuer gebracht
werden auch in bad neuenahr ahrweiler
ist es so ich sagte er eben schon die
bundeswehr ist heute hier auch vor ort
gewesen
sanitäter es gibt ganz viele private
hilfe aber tatsächlich ist es so auch
die offiziellen stellen also die sind
auch vertreten hier tatsächlich polizei
eben auch dann vielen dank für den
moment bobic irian nach bad neuenahr
ahrweiler und wir werfen den blick auf
einen beziehungsweise führen das
gespräch fort mit einem der schon viele
katastrophengebiete gesehen hat der
mainzer arzt gerhard trabert sie sind
unterwegs mit ihrem team schon lange in
katastrophengebieten sie sind
allgemeinmediziner und professor für
sozialmedizin und sozialpsychiatrie und
waren auch im irak und in syrien und
jetzt zuletzt am wochenende im westen
deutschlands können sie uns einschätzen
können sie uns sagen was sie dort
gesehen haben
ja das ist ja jetzt schon von von vielen
berichtet worden für mich war persönlich
es etwas ganz besonderes in zwei stunden
in einem krisengebiet sein zu können mit
dem auto sonst bin ich mit dem flugzeug
längere zeit unterwegs und dann haben
wir auch wir waren ihnen schuld wir
waren in brück und sind dann nach altena
und dort in den stadtteil in den
ortsteil kreuzberg und das war natürlich
auch für uns unglaublich die die diese
verwüstung wir haben mit unserem mobilen
arztmobil versucht die menschen zu
versorgen das fehlen da erstmal spe das
medikamente gegen den bluthochdruck
blutzucker erkrankungen kleinere wunden
behandelt kinder untersucht aber die
hauptaufgabe war das zuhören das zuhören
über das was die menschen dort erfahren
erlitten haben so dicht am tod gewesen
zu sein zu geglaubt zu haben ich sterbe
jetzt mit ansehen zu müssen wie andere
gestorben sind nicht helfen zu können
zu berichten dass die enkeltochter einen
toten im garten gefunden hat dass ein
mann und eine frau mit mit ihren kindern
versucht haben ans ufer zu schwimmen und
dann die frau mit dem kind in den fluten
untergegangen ist dass das war natürlich
sehr beeindruckend und macht sehr
traurig und sehr nachdenklich und da ist
es ja gerade meine intention darauf
hinzuweisen wie wichtig es ist jetzt und
in zukunft das thema traumatisierung
einfach mit zu berücksichtigen die
menschen sind traumatisiert viele und
wenn ich da gerade noch mal so ein
bisschen ausholen darf wir unterscheiden
eine primäre traumatisierung jetzt
einfach ausgedrückt ich bin selbst das
opfer ich bin im wasser gewesen habe
gerade noch überlebt eine sekundäre
traumatisierung ist wenn jemand
beobachtet dass jemand in gefahr ist das
ist übrigens auch das was sehr viele
helfer jetzt erleben und erleiden
das sind darf man nicht vergessen und
auch sehr viele journalistinnen und
journalisten und die tiere
traumatisierung die tritt dann ein wenn
ich mit meinem primären und sekundären
traum habe ich nicht öffnen kann wenn
ihnen jemand zuhört wenn es keine
möglichkeit gibt das erfahrende
auszutauschen und dann wissen wir aus
der wissenschaft dass diese tänze
traumatisierung dann gravierender ist
als die primäre oder sekundäre dann
kommt es zu einer chronifizierung dann
kommt es zu flashbacks deshalb ist es
mir so wichtig immer wieder darauf
hinzuweisen
wir müssen jetzt ich weiß dass sehr
viele
dessen intervention teams dort sind das
notfallseelsorge dort ist sie muss jetzt
gezielt eingesetzt werden da gibt es
noch logistische probleme aber wir
müssen perspektivisch daran denken
angebote für die menschen zu schaffen ja
dass das vielleicht mal als ersten
eindruck
das heißt was brauchen diese menschen
jetzt am nötigsten
natürlich brauchen sie wasser strom
sie brauchen eine medizinische
grundversorgung
sie brauchen die solidarität die
empathie all das ist sehr sehr wichtig
aber auch jetzt ist es schon wichtig
dass sowohl helfer als auch betroffene
die möglichkeit haben über das erlebte
einfach einmal in eine ruhephase reden
zu können deshalb ist die
notfallseelsorge so wichtig die
krisenintervention das gespräch ist
jetzt schon wichtig und wir haben das
problem häufig feuerwehr polizei ich
kenne das selbst aus den rettungsdienst
ich bin ja auch notarzt
das ist häufig sehr männerdominiert und
wir männer tun uns immer noch schwer
einzugestehen wir brauchen unterstützung
wir brauchen hilfe
auch weinen zu können emotionalität
zeigen zu können
das wird immer noch damit verbunden dass
das ein zeichen von schwäche sei
das ist es natürlich nicht es ist ein
zeichen von stärke hilfe zu suchen und
anzunehmen
und genau da müssen eben auch die
polizei die feuerwehr drk thw das muss
mit bedacht werden gerade im nachgang
wenn ich in einem kriseneinsatz bin gibt
es ein briefing eine vorbereitung und
ein debriefing eine nachbereitung wo wir
über solche erlebnisse über tod über das
erleben von stärken von leid uns
austauschen können und auch mit dem
angebot wenn er in einer woche in einem
monat in sechs monaten
das gefühl habt ihr braucht
unterstützung dann kriegt ihr diese
unterstützung und das muss für die
betroffenen und für die helfer und auch
für die journalistinnen und journalisten
jetzt schon mitgedacht werden weil es
eben auch eine situation ist auf die
hier in diesem kontext in dieser
umgebung niemand vorbereitet war also
wenn man sich anguckt dass viele
freiwillige feuerwehr leute zum beispiel
auch vor ort sind und retten und
versuchen zu helfen
die jungs sind die eigentlich damit
sonst gar nichts zu tun haben die
normale berufe haben die als elektro
ingenieure oder sonstwas arbeiten und
wissen okay es gibt einsätze mit brendan
s gibt verkehrsunfälle darauf sind wir
vielleicht vorbereitet oder darüber
können wir miteinander reden aber dass
das ist noch mal was ganz anderes sind
wir da schon weit genug
offensichtlich nicht wenn man sich das
anhört was sie gerade sagen
also wir sind ja auf dieses ausmaß einer
katastrophe nicht vorbereitet und ich
glaube nicht dass es für alle
einsatzkräfte ein briefing gegeben hat
auch kein debriefing wir haben sowieso
das wissen wir in deutschland zu wenig
psychotherapeuten bestuhlte psychologen
und ärzte und entsprechende angebote für
traumatisierte menschen wir wissen dass
aus dem kontext der betroffenheit von
geflüchteten menschen
ich denke wir sind da nicht gut
aufgestellt
wir müssen uns jetzt damit
auseinandersetzen und wir müssen
angebote schaffen und das müssen wie
gesagt nicht unbedingt immer
therapeutische angebote seien sondern
das sind gesprächsgruppen das ist ein
gesprächskreis natürlich sollten da
geschulte weiter mit im boot sein die
das gespür haben die erfahrung haben und
ich gebe ihnen vollkommen recht es sind
so viele junge einsatzkräfte ich habe
mit polizisten gesprochen die mir dann
berichtet haben in der ruhigen minute ja
sie haben auch neun tote gesehen
feuerwehr menschen und natürlich auch
die betroffenen selbst ja bekannte
verwandte sterben zusehen
und da müssen wir etwas tun und und mir
ist es auch immer wieder wichtig noch
einmal ganz besonders auf die kinder
hinzuweisen
die kinder sie sind jetzt schon durch
die pandemie häufig ein stück weg
traumatisiert jetzt kommt so ein
ereignis dort und kinder werden nicht
aktiv es einklagen ich brauche hilfe
sondern kinder ziehen sich vielleicht
zurück sind introvertiert haben
vielleicht so genannte regression
syndrome dh die fallen wieder in
entwicklungsstufen zurück die
zurückliegende schon wieder am daumen
haben trennungsängste dessen ein wenn
sie schlafen also das ist ganz wichtig
kinder reagieren zum teil auch nicht so
wie wir erwachsenen wenn wir eine
depression haben sondern sie sind
hyperaktiv und dann wird das fehl
interpretiert also da ist mein plädoyer
mein appell denkt an diese kinder bitte
plant jetzt schon proaktiv möglichkeiten
für kinder darüber reden zu können
es ist ja wenn ich sie da gerade
unterbrechen dafür haben bei corona oft
darüber berichtet dass die kinder und
jugendpsychiatrie in voll sind das die
wartelisten unendlich lang sind und das
schon in dieser situation der bedarf an
hilfe unglaublich groß war und dieses
land offenbar nicht in der lage ist zu
helfen nun wird das ausmaß noch mal
größer also brauchen wir mehr geld mehr
kinder und jugendpsychiater mehr
sozialarbeiter in den schulen absolute
das sind natürlich fehler die wir in der
vergangenheit schon immer getan haben
obwohl viele darauf hingewiesen haben
die müssen korrigiert werden
jetzt aktuell können wir natürlich nicht
warten bis diese fehler korrigiert sind
jetzt müssen wir kreativ sein
jetzt muss es im kindergarten in der
schule im kinderhort muss es angebote
geben wir müssen schon jetzt planen
erlebnispädagogische maßnahmen für die
kinder wo sie mit anderen betroffenen
zusammen kommen wo sie das erlebte
verarbeiten können natürlich müssen da
auch fachleute dabei sein also hier
müssen wir solche kreative angebote den
kindern anbieten das ist
so elementar sonst kommt es zu einer
chronifizierung von diesen traumata und
vor allen dingen bei kindern ist eins
noch ganz wichtig wenn kinder es nicht
erklärt bekommen kindgerecht was da
passiert ist dann tendieren kinder immer
dazu in schuld fantasien auch sich
selbst als eine mögliche ursache des
ganzen leids zu interpretieren
das ist ein ganz normaler form des
narzismus die welt ist eben sehr stark
auf das kind gezogen deshalb ist es so
wichtig und wir schützen kinder nicht
indem wir sie vor solchen ernsten
schwierigen themen ausschließen das muss
uns eben auch immer wieder bewusst sein
ich arbeite da einem anderen kontext
gerade auch mit kindern die von tod und
sterben der eltern mit betroffen sind
und wir haben da wirklich sehr viel
erfahrung und es zeigt uns immer wieder
die kinder sind auch erleichtert wenn
diese themen mit ihnen angesprochen
werden dann werden sie nämlich auch
ernst genommen und das ist etwas ganz
ganz entscheidendes vertrat es gibt wenn
ich hier in denen in die kommentare
gucken muss ich leider sagen menschen
denen nicht klar zu sein scheint wie
ernst das ist worüber sie hier gerade
reden und es gibt bestimmt auch leute
die sagen meine güte was geht mich das
alles an und hier bei mir zuhause ich
bin doch verschont geblieben und mich
trifft das sowieso nicht
ich weiß nicht wie sie das sonst in
ihrer arbeit erleben durfte sie umso
mehr wenn sie sehen die katastrophe
passiert vor der eigenen haustür und
leute wie user denn nahm mich jetzt
garantiert nicht vorlesen werde sind
einfach nur in der lage müll zu
schreiben ohne irgendwie empathie oder
konstruktionen oder irgendwas zu leisten
wie wie gehen sie damit um wenn sie
merken dass sie helfen und dass sie
gutes tun und es leute gibt die sich
offenbar weigern gute menschen zu sein
ja dass das 50 tagen das ignoriere ich
ja das ist ja nicht kompetent und nicht
von sach- und fachverstand geprägt und
das hat auch nichts mit humanität mit
respekt und würde zu tun
ich kann verstehen dass manche menschen
das nicht so auf ihre agenda haben
dieses thema traumatisierung natürlich
lädt jetzt erstmal
die das überleben die behandlung von
verletzten im vordergrund dass der müll
weg kommt dass die straßen die brücken
die infrastruktur wieder hergestellt
wird aber häufig wird genau das
unterschätzt was ist mit uns menschen
macht wir sind eben sehr sensible wesen
in aller regel
und dann dann kommt so etwas dann der
der stärkste in anführungszeichen jetzt
mal der stärkste mann der jetzt sagt ja
da muss man einfach durch
dann kommen die gedanken dann kommen die
erinnerungen dann kommen die bilder
zurück dann kommt erst das reflektieren
was ist da eigentlich passiert wie nah
war ich meinem tod in dieser situation
und das ist etwas diese form von
kontrollverlust für das eigene leben ist
dann so irritierend so verunsichert
verunsichernd unter brauche es eben
diese unterstützung dann brauche es
diese solidarität das ist jetzt schon
etwas ganz wichtiges das die menschen
spüren da sind helfer da ist die
feuerwehr da ist die polizei da ist die
bundeswehr da ist das thw das ist da ist
das drk das sind einzelne einzelne
helfer
das ist schon was ganz wichtiges um
etwas schon in dieser situation gegen
eine chronische traumatisierung zu tun
aber das dürfen wir nicht aus den augen
verlieren das ist etwas ganz wichtiges
und das muster speck perspektiv ich muss
das ganz oben auf der agenda stehen wenn
es still geworden ist wenn nicht mehr
der fokus auf diese orte sind die
menschen werden dann weiterleiten
sie werden weiter daran denken was ihnen
passiert ist und sie brauchen dann
gerade dann unsere unterstützung und
hilfe sagt der arzt gerhard trabert
vielen dank dass sie bei uns in der
sendung haben waren und vielen dank für
diese sehr eindrucksvollen berichte auch
von vor ort und vielen dank auch für das
was sie gesagt haben was getan werden
müsste
und genau das tun wir jetzt wie
ignorieren alle
liegen kommentare in diesen chats und
beschränken uns auf die konstruktiven
und danken sehr für die vielen fragen
die sich vor allem damit
auseinandersetzen wie konnte das
passieren und warum konnte das nicht
verhindert werden und hätten unsere
frühwarnsysteme nicht viel früher warnen
müssen oder was ist überhaupt mit
unseren frühwarnsystemen los und um das
gleich in ruhe zu erörtern mit einem
katastrophenschutzexperten schauen wir
erst noch einmal das ausmaß der
katastrophe an mein kollege jonas
postpaid fasst es zusammen
auch am fünften tag nach dem
verheerenden hochwasser werden im
rheinland-pfälzischen landkreis
ahrweiler immer noch tote geborgen
nach angaben der polizei sind hier
bislang 117 todesopfer gefunden worden
doch die zahl wird wahrscheinlich noch
steigen mehr als 740 menschen wurden
durch das hochwasser verletzt zahlreiche
weitere sind noch vermisst wie viele
kann niemand sagen
im benachbarten nordrhein-westfalen
melden die behörden 46 tote im besonders
stark betroffenen erftstadt besteht
weiterhin gefahr
hier war durch die fluten ein großer
krater entstanden
dort könnten noch weitere erdmassen
nachrutschen so die bürgermeisterin von
erftstadt gegenüber dem radiosender wdr
aufatmen können dafür die anwohner rund
um die steinbachtalsperre bei euskirchen
hier ist lotte bezirksregierung köln
kein dammbruch mehr zu befürchten
auch wenn es mit den aufräumarbeiten
voran geht steht den helferinnen und
helfern noch viel arbeit bevor
vielerorts ist die infrastruktur
zusammengebrochen weggerissene straßen
und brücken fehlende strom und
trinkwasserversorgung
wann es für die betroffenen wieder eine
rückkehr zur normalität gibt ist nicht
absehbar
klar ist jedoch es wird monate dauern
und ich begrüße in der sendung wolf
dombrowsky er ist seit 2008 professor
für katastrophenmanagement an der
steinbeis hochschule berlin
von 2002 bis 2008 war er leiter der
katastrophenforschungsstelle kfs in kiel
und ist mitglied der ständigen konferenz
für katastrophenvorsorge herr dombrowski
was ist ihr fazit im moment wo
hat es am meisten nach dem was sie nach
dieser flut katastrophe gesehen haben
ich glaube nicht dass man sagen kann
dass es im augenblick hat sondern wer
diese schuttmassen sieht der weiß es
wird einfach alle kräfte brauchen damit
wir wieder zugang haben damit die
elektrizität wieder hergestellt wird
kommunikation trinkwasserversorgung
brauch wasserversorgung dh die
unmittelbaren bedürfnisse stehen im
augenblick tatsächlich im vordergrund
wenn man die strukturellen probleme sich
anschaut dann muss man eigentlich in
zeiträumen von 50 60 vielleicht sogar
100 jahren denken weil wir viel zu dicht
besiedelt haben weil viele kommunen es
erlaubt haben in bereiche hinein zu
bauen die hochwasser gefährdet sind weil
wir es sehr lange zeit versäumt haben
gefährdungs karten anzulegen risiko
kataster zu bestimmen weil wir unser
wahlsystem abgebaut haben und es schon
seit mindestens seit den 70er jahren nur
papiertiger gibt aber keine ernsthaften
bemühungen ein neues wahlsystem
aufzubauen
wir haben gesehen dass manche apps
entwickelt worden sind
aber sie sind noch zu sehr nah wie soll
man sagen erprobungs stadium statt dass
ich schon nutzen und was man auch der
fairness halber sagen muss das sagen ja
alle meteorologen derartige starkregen
ereignisse lassen sich nicht exakt also
regional exakt vorhersagen
sie lassen sich nicht in den mengen
exakt vorhersagen und wir müssten hier
im prinzip ganz neu denken
beispielsweise auf jedes haus eine
wetterstation mit einem regen messer und
ein windmesser so dass wir für jedes
haus eine gefährdung sun zeige hätten so
wie beispielsweise einen ein rauchmelder
dass sie aber auch aus der summe dieser
ganzen anzeigegeräte gebiets spezifische
warnsignale hätten
die ein sirenensystem beispielsweise
niemals leisten könnte also wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen langfristigen
problemen strukturellen problemen und
nehmen unmittelbaren nehmen was den
menschen jetzt fehlt herr dombrowski
dann lassen sie uns das ein bisschen
aufdröseln weil sie sagten es gibt
eigentlich alle systeme die die man
bräuchte die die gibt es zumindest in
teilen aber sie funktionieren vielleicht
nicht so gut elke farbe weiß über
youtube daraufhin eine britische
forscherin wirft der deutschen politik
angesichts der hochwasserkatastrophe
monumentales system versagen vor
deutschland sei rechtzeitig und präzise
gewarnt worden passiert sei nichts das
spielt an auf das europäische
frühwarnsystem das ist ja gibt was ist
denn da schiefgelaufen
also auch hier sprechen sie eine
diskussion an die wir im grunde genommen
seit gründung der bundesrepublik führen
die föderale konstruktion führt dazu
dass jedes land ein eigenes system und
nach möglichkeit ein besseres als der
nachbar haben möchte und aus diesem viel
klang entsteht eigentlich nichts
vernünftiges darf ich genau an dieser
stelle hat die entschuldigung darf ich
genau an dieser stelle ein zitat von
bundesinnenminister war seehofer von
heute morgen unterbringen der sagt ich
möchte nicht an der föderale struktur
des katastrophenschutzes rütteln
diese ist richtig und zwar seit
jahrzehnten o-ton innenminister ja was
bleibt die man anderes übrig als diesen
quatsch immer wieder zu wiederholen
dadurch dass wir in jedem bundesland die
gleichen verkehrszeichen haben wird auch
der föderalismus auch nicht kaputt
gemacht was man fordern muss also corona
hat es doch gezeigt da haben wir noch
faxgeräte und meldesysteme bis zum ak
die übers wochenende nicht funktionieren
das ist für eine bundesrepublik
deutschland im 21 jahrhundert einfach
unwürdig und dass wir immer noch kein
einheitliches meldesystem haben dass wir
kein einheitliches triage system haben
das kann es doch nicht am föderalismus
wohl aber an den eifersüchteleien und
den den
wünschen von einzelnen landesfürsten
dass man immer besser sein will als der
andere
also warum einigt man sich nicht für
solche zentralen probleme auf ein
einheitliches gesamtsystem das macht
auch den journalismus nicht kaputt das
heißt also sie würden sagen föderalismus
in dieser sache macht überhaupt keinen
sinn wir brauchen leitplanken und dann
kann man sich innerhalb dieser
leitplanken immer noch bewegen richtig
ich möchte gerne ein paar kommentare von
userinnen und usern mit einbringen hier
schreibt zum beispiel kino über facebook
ich kann absolut nicht nachvollziehen
dass man sich ernsthaft traut jahrelange
versäumnisse beim katastrophenschutz nun
beim klima zu suchen und noch ernsthaft
für etwas jeden tag appelliert was die
vordere nicht selbst bezahlen
ich lese das so dass man eigentlich mehr
geld in den katastrophenschutz stecken
müsste oder ist das also ich hoffe kino
das ist die richtige stoßrichtung und
ist das was weil was sie aus ihrer sicht
auch unterstützen würden also ich stimme
diesen kommentar vollkommen zu
wenn man nach japan schaut die dort
beispielsweise ganze städte unter
tunnels sind damit riesen wassermassen
die aus dem gebirge kommen abschließen
können wie man schleusentore gebaut hat
wie man sozial ganze häuserzeilen auf
stelzen gestellt hat dann sieht man was
heute technisch und strukturell alles
möglich ist das heißt katastrophenschutz
bei uns heißt immer noch nachsorge wenn
es eingetreten ist
das heißt die man würde an der
hervorragenden arbeit der
hilfsorganisation der feuerwehr des thw
rütteln wollen aber die kommen erst wenn
es zu spät ist das was wir brauchen ist
doch mittlerweile eine strukturelle
bauliche architektonische nutzungs
mäßige vorbereitung die hochwasser 2002
an den schlüssel haben dazu geführt dass
beispielsweise der rein von der mündung
bis zur quelle kartiert ist
das ganze risiko gerade ab gemessen
worden sind dass man retention gebiete
ausgewiesen und erweitert hat das heißt
hier hat man ein hydraulisches system
rein entwickelt das mittlerweile ganz
gut funktioniert dann hat man solche
spundwände die mobil sind wie in köln
das heißt hier hat man vorbereitungen
getroffen die über jahrzehnte gewachsen
und entwickelt worden sind aber noch
längst nicht in anderen gebieten benutzt
werden würde der seien konkrete der
halle ganz massiv umdenken würde das
denn an der ahr jetzt ganz konkret
bedeuten dass man menschen die ihre
häuser verloren haben die direkt in
flussnähe gestanden haben sagen muss
sorry aber dieses haus können sie an
dieser stelle nicht wieder so hinstellen
wie es war wenn man aus sicht der
betroffenen denkt dann sagen die um
gottes willen das ist mein grundstück
mein haus ich habe hier gewohnt ich habe
meine freunde völlig verständlich wenn
man aus sicht des katastrophenschutzes
und zwar eines strukturellen
katastrophenschutzes denkt müsste man
genau das machen und sagen das hier ist
überschwemmungs gefährdet hier wird
nicht wieder aufgebaut hier kommen
retention gebieten so müsste es
eigentlich laufen damit machen sie sich
wahrscheinlich kurzfristig nicht beliebt
mit dieser aussage und das betrifft
natürlich auch nicht nur diese gebiete
sondern das ist ja ein problem das es in
ganz deutschland gibt dass die häuser
wie sie schon sagten über jahrzehnte
viel zu nah an die flüsse gebaut wurden
oder immer mehr flächen zubetoniert
werden so dass das wasser nicht
abfließen kann also auch das eigentlich
eine gesamtdeutsche herausforderung eine
frage habe ich aber ein punkt möchte ich
dazu doch noch anlagen
es gibt gegenüber von köln eine gemeinde
rothenkirchen die haben eine
hochwasserschutz gemeinschaft gegründet
sie haben selber eine app entwickelt die
haben smart homes entwickelt wo
beispielsweise ab einem bestimmten
pegelstand automatisch schutzwände an
ihren teller fenstern bis kellertüren
hochfahren
die können ihre häuser hermetisch
abdichten das heißt es gibt auch auf der
individuellen seitenschutz verkehr
natürlich muss man hier sehr aufpassen
nicht dass ich das den einzelnen
hauseigentümern überwälzen möchte und
gegen solche massen wie sie gekommen
sind also pegelstände um die 8 meter da
nützt auch eine solche hochfahrende
spundwand nichts mehr sondern werden
ganze gebäude unterspült und kippen aber
hier muss doch eben im einklang mit den
hausbesitzern mit den gemeinden mit den
ländern mit dem bund müssen
entwicklungen initiiert werden wo man
einen wirklich wirkungsvollen
strukturellen katastrophenschutz aufbaut
hier kommt zustimmung aus der community
so viel york schreibt über youtube er
hat definitiv recht und michael binz
schreibt das gibt es an der mosel auch
also offenbar gibt es mehrere solcher
solcher modelle
ich möchte gerne noch etwas ansprechen
was sie gerade genannt haben nämlich das
faxgerät wenn man das wort sirene hört
dann könnte man erst mal denken sirene
das gab es im kalten krieg dann hat man
es eben abgebaut weil man sagte die der
kalte krieg ist vorbei man braucht es
nicht mehr
jetzt sagen alle wir brauchen aber diese
sirene wieder das heißt das ist kein
fossil aus der urzeit wie das faxgerät
was nun tatsächlich abgeschafft gehören
sondern das ist ein alt anmutendes aber
für heutige zeiten angemessen und not
angemessenes und notwendiges
instrumentarium was wir aus ihrer sicht
bräuchten sie haben ja angesprochen dass
ich mal leiter der
katastrophenforschungsstelle war da hat
uns das bundesinnenministerium nach
einem gutachten gefragt ob man dass die
reden system abschaffen soll
wir haben damals schon gesagt um gottes
willen nein das hat eine weckfunktion
das hat eine spontan funktion wenn der
ton losgeht wissen alle leute es ist
getan
sie hören es und dann kam die die
besserwisser und sagt ja aber handy und
individuelles und gebiets spezifisch
aber wir hatten handy gehört dass nachts
also lange rede kurzer sinn natürlich
brauchen wir ein solches
funktionierendes system das schnell alle
leute aus dem bett gejagt
eine abschlussfrage hätte ich noch an
sie armin schuster war gestern zu gast
im zdf heute journal der leiter der
jetzige leiter des amtes für
katastrophenschutz der hat zum einen
gesagt wir haben versucht vieles richtig
zu machen hat das amt aus seiner sicht
auch an anderer stelle hat er allerdings
sehr quasi darum gebeten dass man dem
amt und seine arbeit mehr aufmerksamkeit
schenkt und dass man auch mehr in der
eigenverantwortung ist zuzusehen wie das
amt informiert welche möglichkeiten es
gibt sich zu informieren welche apps man
herunterladen muss
was ist ihre bilanz des amtes für
katastrophenschutz nach dieser
katastrophe also die menschen die dort
arbeiten haben wirklich meine
solidarität weil sie nämlich allesamt
viel mehr können als sie dürfen das
bundesamt wird in seinen fähigkeiten so
kurz gehalten das ist ein jammer wenn
man in die usa schaut wo die federal
emergency management agency klima viel
mehr kompetenzen hat viel besser
arbeiten kann forschen darf freiräume
hat ja hier ist alles was das bundesamt
macht ist ja sozusagen wird immer
empfunden von den ländern als die wollen
in unsere katastrophenschutz kompetenz
hineinreden
und da sind so viele eifersüchteleien
und so viele nickligkeiten dass man nur
sagen kann der arme schuster was soll er
machen
dombrowski vielen herzlichen dank dass
sie bei uns in der sendung waren und
vielen dank für die klaren worte danke
ihnen und ich bedanke mich bei ihnen
liebe userinnen und user zu hause für
die dann doch vielfach sehr
konstruktiven kommentare und für alle
die die auf dem laufenden bleiben wollen
verweise ich auf unserem live blog auf
zdf heute dort sind sie mit allen
aktuellen informationen immer gut
versorgt und natürlich auch in den
sendungen bei uns im programm und mit
einem zdf spezial das heute abend direkt
im anschluss an die heute -nachrichten
läuft vielen dank fürs zuschauen machen
sie es gut